another day closer to Avengers infinity
war and if you're like me you're
wondering where the heck is the soul
stone there's a lot of theories out
there concerning where it's at some have
already been disproven and some of them
are just crazy out there
like Iron Man himself being a soul stone
so in this video we'll be going over
some of those theories and determining
which ones make the most sense but
before we get started
fun fact for you if you push the little
red button you usually get subscribed to
my channel I don't know try it up it's
usually works well performance issues
not uncommon to start off let's do a
brief recap of where the other five
Infinity stones are located right now
the space stone or the tesseract look
he's got it he totally took it at the
end of Thor Ragnarok and this has been
confirmed to us in the trailers the
reality stone or the ether at the end of
Thor at the dark world the warriors 3
took it and gave it to the collector the
time stone currently sits and dr.
Strange's necklace the power stone this
is the orb that was in the guardians of
the galaxy at the end of the movie they
give it to the Nova Corps for
safekeeping
the mine stone this was in the scepter
that Thanos originally gave to Loki and
now sits in the forehead of vision and
last but not least the soul stone
Deadpool's got it that's why he can't
die thanks for watching guys what nice
ok fine we'll go over some more theories
that actually makes sense
let's start with the Wakanda theory when
Black Panther came out a lot of us
thought that they were going to
introduce the soul stone to us in this
movie but they didn't and not only did
they not introduce it the Russo brothers
actually came out and blatantly said the
soul stones not in Wakanda these were
some good theories like the soul stone
was the heart-shaped herb or it's what
allowed Black Panther to see his
ancestors but they shut it down so
moving on another theory that's a little
crazier than others is what I briefly
mentioned before and that is that Tony
Stark himself is actually at the soul
stone yeah this one was a little weird
to me too
it came from the fact that an Iron Man
to Tony's dad said his greatest creation
will always be Tony but I don't think
that means he's the soul stone and I
don't really see Tony
freaking down into a little stone and
being put into thanasis gauntlet but hey
we'll see moving on the next few
theories actually stem from one fear in
itself and that is the Thanos theory if
you're unfamiliar with what the Thanos
theory is the theory states that the
Infinity stones are hiding in objects
that make up the mad Titans named Thanos
as you can see all the letters are
covered except for the H so what could
the H be one theory is Heimdall this
actually makes a lot of sense because
handle is a beam of incredible power and
he can see every single living soul in
existence does the soul stone give him
that power also the soul stones orange
and you know he's kind of orange too I
guess we'll see when the movie comes out
if he's managed to keep a huge secret
this whole entire time another theory is
hella hella is the goddess of death but
is she the goddess of death because she
possesses the soul stone the soul stone
gives its wielder the power to control
souls both alive and dead is this how
she becomes the goddess of death and
gets her power if this is true it's
probably really hard to kill her seeing
as she's the goddess of death and
possesses the soul stone if this theory
is true I'm guessing she's still alive
after Thor Ragnarok and I'm sure we'll
be seeing her an Avengers infinity war
or Avengers for another theory is that
the H stands for him him being Adam
warlock I so hope this theory is true
because Adam warlock is one of my
all-time favorite characters in the
comics he's freaking awesome and he even
wields the Infinity Gauntlet in the
comics they introduced Adam to the MCU
by showing his cocoon and the
post-credit scenes of guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 but unfortunately it has
been stated that Adam warlock will not
make his debut in Avengers infinity war
and will be starring and guardians of
the galaxy vol 3 speaking of guardians
of the galaxy if this next theory is
true I am going to be very angry there's
a rumor that stays you need to kill a
loved one to get your hands on the soul
stone who could fan os-- the mad Titan
possibly love well he kind of loves
Gamora his adopted daughter and in
guardians of the galaxy vol 1
he states that she is his favorite
daughter we even have a flashback scene
and
the trailers that have been released of
him abducting her as a child and it
doesn't seem like an unhappy scene we
even seen her little baby hand grabbing
thanasis finger if this theory is true
they better used that soulstone to bring
her back to life that's all I'm saying
laughs hiding real pain the last of the
theories that I find noteworthy isn't
really a theory that helps us determine
where the soul stone is but it's just a
really cool theory and that is that
Captain Marvel is trapped inside the
soul stone so to start off Captain
Marvel takes place between Avengers
infinity war and Avengers 4 and it takes
place in the 1990s but it's rumored that
she makes an appearance and Avengers 4
being one of the main characters it's
also rumored that Captain Marvel will
explore the quantum realm which is the
same quantum realm from ant-man the soul
stone actually has another sort of realm
itself called soul world and the soul
stone can trap Souls inside of it the
theory is that if Thanos has to
sacrifice a soul to get the soul stone
then it might release a soul that's
already trapped inside of it if this is
true then it would bring Captain Marvel
into current time and into Avengers 4
but then again these are all just
theories I think it's likely that one of
these is true with the exception of the
Tony Stark one my name is Tony Stark and
I'm not afraid of you
I know you're a coward so I've decided
that you just died but what do you guys
think I'd love to hear your thoughts and
I'd love to hear if you've heard any
other crazy theories that might make
sense let me know in the comment section
below I'd love to discuss it and hey if
it's cool enough and makes sense I might
do a video on it don't forget to like
this video and hey give that subscribe
button a try just might work for you
thank you so much for watching guys
woof woof